1996年,
日本將棋的七大頭銜被同一個人全部拿走,
史上第一次,
他叫Yoshiharu Habu,
15歲當上職業棋士下了40年。
去年累計到1600勝,將棋就是日本的象棋,也是最早被AI追過去的領域之一。
今年9月公開的這段訪談裡,他講了一件跟多數人想的相反的事,AI越強,棋士眼前的路越看不清楚。
節目是Newspeaks的Weekly Oche,主持人是媒體藝術家Yuichi Oche。
在2017年,AI在正式對局贏了當時拿著著名人頭銜的騎士之後,職業騎士反過來批判。
來拿AI當研究工具
UHO起來
自己做生成式AI的研究
他把將其當成
走在前面的例子來問
你會覺得這條路是屬於自己的領域嗎?
當然了
在AI世界的歷史中
遊戲世界的結果比較容易出現
所以現在在其他世界也發揮出類似的現象
不過
我認為是這樣的
但我認為
在現實世界中
與在數碼空間中
即是在電腦世界中
關聯的世界
基本上是有不同的
所以我認為
那裡的現象和反應
是有所不同的
我認為在前段時間
我一直在研究生成AI
我一直在研究智能智能
但在2012年
我仍然在自己的手中
創作了半份的程序
現在我沒有在自己的手中
創作任何一個程序
但當我用這個程序來比喻
是非常有趣的
如果我用自己的手來刺
它的精緻度就會減弱
所以我不會再用自己的手來刺
所以我覺得自己
是很奇怪的
但反過來說
而人類選擇什麼都沒有做過,
人類會去選擇哪個地方有價值,
哪個地方有可能性
人類不會想到這些,
所以我們要選擇哪個項目、哪個項目要努力分析、研究
這是我所謂的研究主題
人類一直以來都將製造作為一種價值
但如果將製造作任由其他人執行
選擇才會變得非常重要
是的
因為製造出來的東西會出現很多
那麼選擇之處或是在哪裡做
選擇才會變得更重要
是的 我認為
正如我們所謂的世界
同樣是在世界上,有很多類似於袋工的領域
如果進入袋工的領域,有些領域會通過多餘的時間而無法生產任何東西
所以,
雖然技術上可以調查,
但如何逃脫袋工的領域也是很重要的
你剛才提到要如何選擇去做袋工的領域是很重要的
例如演習率的計算
演習率的計算是可以永遠的
但在競技上也有這樣的局面
當你開始調查這個局面
就像是一個時間的障礙
你會覺得這個計算是永遠的
或是沒有結論
或是現在的計算也沒有意義
這些事情都要看清楚
然後在關注某個題目
或是要做的事情
你會更加集中
這是很重要的
在大局中,你會想到自己的理念,然後就放棄了
你會想到自己的理念,然後就放棄了
對,AI進行的時候,會有更多的情況
會有更多的情況,會有更多的情況
最近?
最近比較多
那些比較多
我明白
比較明確的確認自己的方法更好
總是有點廣泛的
有些人是沒有這樣的方法
而繼續繼續進行
因此
相反
在這種情況下
最近的商業世界
很難感受到這種反應
好有趣
那是說
從表面來說
味道是不一樣的
是的
以前是這樣的
是有一定程度的明確地向前移動
但是現在是一直在暗中尋找
或是在無意中進行的情況下
這種情況非常多
那可能是因為大家與AI互動
未知的手段開始發展
未知的手段可能會進入
不太明白的結尾
意外地大家都在用
或是在考慮
在商業世界的情況下,在與專業戰鬥中,基本上會遇到不一樣的局面
從那裡開始,無論如何進行,都會是不一樣的世界
並且從那裡開始,會變得更加複雜,並且會發生更加無法理解的情況
有很多情況是這樣的
在世界的看法上
如果有畫面
就能夠解決任何問題
我認為這並不是這樣的
不明顯的地方
AI一出現就把局面攪亂
兩年後會怎樣幾乎沒人說得準
大家只確定電力跟半導體很重要
所以我認為這樣做是很難做的
我非常感覺到
是的
所以我認為
這樣做會有很大的差異
在這種情況下
如果有不可能的測試
或是有不可能的事件
就會有很大的差異
但是我在大學教學生的時候
在這種緊迫的局面下,有很多女生是沒有動力的
是的,我認為是這樣的
有很多女生是不知所措,腳沒有進步
對
如果看見有這樣的女生停下來
你對她的聲音是怎樣的呢?
誒?
我認為是旅行
旅行
那是日常的感受,而不是普通的感受
我認為這種感受是很難忍受的
但全人類,即使是騎士,他們都一直在訓練這種感受
所以在迷糊的局面下,他們也會考慮前進的方法
我認為他們是這樣想的
他們是受到任務教育
然後在大學入學
在不知不覺的局地中
在工作的情況下
我經常接觸到
這種感覺是
是這樣的
但我覺得
不想讓所有人都做
我覺得是健康的
因為有些人喜歡這種事情
有些人有興趣
有興趣
人的精神厚厚的
如果只有這樣的人去做
我覺得會比較健康
如果所有人都在做
洛河沒有放過這一題
他說現實是整個世界都已經起霧
不喜歡這種局面的人
處境只會越來越糟
宇生說現在是過渡期
然後把話接回他前面講過的那個字
最終選擇選擇
我剛才也提到過
我覺得選擇才是個人的特色
也許能夠維持一個從零開始創造出的
有創造性的個性
但我認為繼續選擇的結果
會成為一個人的風格
或是一個人的獨自性
AI下得出人想一百年也想不到的棋
棋士眼前的路反而更悟
在物理每一步選了什麼
Yoshiharu Habu說
那就是一個人的個性
原影片20分鐘
前半段他講了
當江淇聯盟會長的那兩年
就會館有兩個入口
下棋的日子他走左邊
處理會晤的日子走右邊
靠這個切換腦袋
他也講了
怎麼看一個小孩會不會變強
看的是他分不分得出哪裡該想
哪裡想了也沒用
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多